Nye County officials say they will begin  hand counting ballots tomorrow they are  asking for volunteers in a statement  today County Clerk Mark half said in  part over the last two and a half weeks  our team of dedicated Deputy clerks poll  workers and election board officials  successfully implemented a paper ballot  process for Knight County other than  Dropbox and mail ballots received on  Election Day all early vote and election  day ballots were tabulated by 11 59 pm  on November 8th well this demonstrates  that an all-paper ballot process can be  implemented successfully in a tightly  controlled process  the ACLU meantime asking the Secretary  of State to investigate what it says are  party officials working in coordination  with poll workers the hand count is  being done after the ballots were run  through the voting machines we do have  much more on this story and the full  statement on our website  eightnewsnow.com